There's a hidden signal that women
pick up on before you even open your
mouth, and most men
will spend their entire lives completely
unaware of its existence.  What
I'm about to share with you has
absolutely nothing to do with
your height, your bank account,
or how much hair you have left on your head.
It's about the invisible language
your body transmits every single
second of every day, and how
understanding it can almost
immediately change the way women
perceive you.
Not after years of work on yourself,
not after a drastic transformation,
almost immediately.
But before we begin, a small favor:
like this video and let me
know in the comments which city or
country you're watching from today.
I always read the comments and really enjoy
seeing how the women's psychology community
continues to grow.  Now here's
something most
men have never been taught.
Physical appearance is only
part of the attraction equation.
The rest, and this is the most
significant part, is based on
innate psychological signals and these signals,
unlike the face, can
absolutely be trained and calibrated.  This is
exactly what we will talk about in
this video.  I have spent years
studying behavioral psychology,
the science of attraction, and the
nonverbal cues that shape how
we are perceived by others.
What consistently emerges is this:
once a man starts sending the
right signals, women
will describe him as more attractive
than he was the day before, even
when his appearance hasn't changed
at all.  You've seen it before,
right?
A man in the room who on paper
appears to have nothing exceptional,
an average appearance,
ordinary clothing.  Yet a woman hangs on
his every word, laughs, comes closer, her
eyes sparkle.  Meanwhile, you
're standing there with a better wardrobe
and a better CV and
you're thinking about what he has that I don't.  It's not
magic, it's not luck.  These are signs, and
today I'm going to show you 10 of the most powerful ones.
One, the perceptual anchor.  The
human brain doesn't process everything it sees, it
takes shortcuts.
When it perceives a
high-status signal, it automatically assumes
that it now resembles a whole host
of other positive characteristics.
This mechanism is called the
halo effect, and posture is one of its
fastest triggers.
Here's what happens physically.
When the chest is open and the
spine is aligned,
stress hormone levels decrease and the
perception of one's presence
increases.  Walk into a room with
this attitude—chin tucked
, shoulders back, chest
open—and the subconscious of the person
around you
will already assign you a high-
value label, before you've even
uttered a single word.  I have seen
men literally appear taller
in the eyes of others, simply
by changing the way they carry themselves.  Posture
is the fastest means of nonverbal communication
you have.  Use it.  With a
calibrated gaze.
Most men handle
eye contact in one of two
ways: either they
stare too intensely, a type
of gaze that is perceived as
threatening or desperate, or they
look away as soon as they
meet, which is interpreted
as shame or insecurity.
The right move is something in
between.  Maintain eye contact
for about a second, then give a
very subtle nod or a silent half-smile
and look away
voluntarily.  You are the one who started
cutting off contact.
This communicates something
silent but powerful to his brain.  You've noticed her,
you're not nervous, and you're not greedy for
her attention.
This sequence creates a micro spark
of curiosity that lingers.
Once curiosity is
planted, she begins to fill in the gaps
entirely on her own.
Three.  The flashing signal.
It may seem strange the first time you
hear it, but once you pay attention
you will notice it everywhere.
A nervous or overwhelmed person
blinks rapidly.
A person who feels completely at
ease in their surroundings blinks
slowly and calmly.
Start practicing a
calmer blink rate
, slightly slower than what
feels normal to you.
Women perceive this movement on an
unconscious level.  When your eyelids
move calmly and regularly,
they communicate that your nervous system is
regulated, that you belong where you are
, that nothing around you
poses a threat.
4. The drop in pace.  An anxious man
speaks quickly,
speeding up his speech because
somewhere in his nervous system,
he feels he has little time
left, as if he must prove
his point before being
interrupted, but the energy of a
confident man moves slowly and with
awareness.
Try slowing your speaking rate
even just 10% of
what feels natural.  Something
changes.
Your voice gets a little
deeper, warmer, and people
actually find what you say more
convincing.
Women consistently described
men who spoke more slowly
as calmer, more trustworthy, and more
balanced,
although they couldn't explain exactly
why.
A calm voice carries more weight than a
loud voice.
5. The invisible public.
Here's something that will
quietly change the way you
relate to the world.
No one out there is studying your
flaws as intensely as
you are.   That
receding hairline you've been watching for the past 3 years.
She hasn't noticed yet.
The excess weight you've been carrying around since
winter
isn't on his head.
Change happens the moment
you stop compensating, stop
tugging at your shirt, stop
tilting your head to hide a
flaw, stop making invisible
self-corrections.
The moment you stop
hiding,
what you were hiding practically
disappears.
I've seen men in their 50s
completely reinvent their
image, simply by deciding to
stop apologizing for their
appearance.
If strategic silence.
Most men have been
conditioned to believe that silence
in a conversation is a sign of
failure,
so they rush to fill it,
adding unnecessary details.  they go on
too long, they start acting.
The problem is that the more a man acts,
the less confident he actually appears.
Here's the psychological truth that changes
everything.  Silence isn't uncomfortable when you
're calm and confident, only
when you're nervous.
And when tension builds in the
space between words, that tension,
if handled calmly,
actually generates attraction.
Emotional regulation is one of the
rarest and most magnetic qualities a
man can demonstrate.
Think about the men you know who
exude a quieter
authority.   They
never rush to fill a
void.  That composure is
intentional.
Try this, something truly
meaningful,
then be silent.  Don't sweeten your
voice.
Don't try to provoke a
reaction from him, just remain
silent.
You'll be surprised how often he'll lean over
to fill that space, and that
protrusion is a sign of interest.
7. The unhurried frame.
A man who appears to be in a hurry is
communicating something, whether he means it or not,
that he doesn't feel entirely confident.
Speed ​​is an indicator of anxiety.
When you move quickly during
interactions, scan the room while she's
talking, or pick up your phone mid-
conversation, you communicate absence,
and women sense
emotional presence with extraordinary sensitivity.
Change is simple.  Slow
everything down a bit.  Take the glass
slowly.  Turn your head in a
smooth, decisive motion.  When you
sit down, assume a relaxed posture, as
if you had all the time in the world.
This ease communicates confidence
without the need for words.
8. The declarative voice.
True self-confidence doesn't
come loudly, but comes
silently through
affirmations.
The habit to eliminate is that of
ending sentences with a
rising tone, as if you needed
confirmation from someone else.   I've been
really into fitness lately.
Pronounced with a
rising inflection, it sounds as if you are
asking permission.   I've been
really into fitness lately.
Spoken in a flat,
even tone, it conveys the feeling of a
person you simply know.
This small difference in tone,
however subtle, distinguishes leadership
from approval-seeking.
Choose to be a leader.
The man who doesn't need
approval always seems to have it.
Controlled heat.
There are two failed ways to
smile.  The first is smiling
constantly and enthusiastically, which
gives the impression of trying too hard to
please.
The second is to never smile.  Which
appears cold or closed, neither of which
works.  What really works is the
micro smile.
Short, controlled, genuine.
It appears, communicates serenity and vanishes
naturally.
It conveys warmth without desperation,
security without coldness.
Physical attraction can open doors,
but if a woman doesn't feel
emotionally safe with your
energy, she won't walk through them.  She must feel
that being with you costs her nothing.  The
micro smile communicates calm to her, and
calm is contagious.  T E n
spatial presence.
High-level people occupy
space, not aggressively, but
naturally.
Men who feel uncomfortable in
a room shrink,
cross their arms, hunch their
shoulders, keep their legs together, and
curl up into the smallest
possible version of their body.  The solution is
simple.  Take up 10% more space
.  Let your arms hang
relaxed at your sides.  Keep your
feet shoulder-width apart.
Keep your shoulders open and back.   You are
not dominating the room.  You are
simply moving within it,
as someone who belongs there.
Your subconscious picks up on this
signal before you've even
uttered a single syllable.
None of these 10 signs require you
to become a different person.
None of them require
performance.
Rather, performance is the enemy.  When
you eliminate anxious habits, rushing,
over-explaining, and
self-minimization,
what remains is a version of you that
has always existed.
This version doesn't need to be
built from scratch, it just needs to
stop being stifled.
Here's what I want you to take away from
watching this video.
The man who has stopped needing to
be chosen becomes the man who
chooses.
This inner shift is something
women sense the moment they
walk into a room.   It
doesn't need to announce itself, it
just arrives and when it arrives
the whole dynamic changes.
If this gave you something
concrete today, please like and
support female psychology and
leave a comment below telling me
which of these 10 signs struck you
the most.  I read all the comments.